As you probably know,
we took a page from Major League Baseball,
and we filled our audience
with cardboard cutouts.
We had fans send in their
photos, we put in cutouts,
and we had a packed house
the last couple of nights,
maybe you've seen that.
But now it's standing room only.
Check it out. Look at this.
[Andy] Wow.
We have got I mean,
the aisles are clogged,
[Andy] I know
the aisles are just jammed.
I can't move, not just
because it's crowded
because that guy's behind me.
[Canon] Yeah
I don't want to give him
an excuse to leap.
Yeah, no.
Strike
This is in unprecedented,
I've never seen in many
years of doing this show,
I've never seen this many
people in an audience.
In fact, we've had some concern
from the Fire Department.
It's very dangerous.
Yeah, this could be a fire
code violation right now.
[Andy] Right?
I know that a lot of you are concerned
"Conan God forbid there should
be a fire in the theater,
"would you be safe?"
I wanna promise you all I can
get out of here instantly,
if I need to,
even though there are lots
of fans in the aisles,
I know how to take care of number one.
Andy, do me a favor just say
"Conan, I smell smoke
there could be a fire."
Conan I smell smoke there could be a fire.
Taj!
(carton rustling)
Get me to of here!(carton rustling)
Get me out of here!(carton rustling)
I want out!(carton rustling)
Get me out!(carton rustling)
Get me out of here!(carton rustling)
I want out!
(door bangs)
(Andy laughing)
Well, thanks for tuning in, folks.
We'll be back tomorrow with
more of whatever this is.
(Canon panting)
Okay, that was a worthwhile exercise,
I do hope I didn't offend any of my fans,
who sent in cutouts and
just saw them crushed.
On a sincere note,
I do wanna say that these
cutouts are helping me.
I'm very appreciative that all of you,
took the time to send in
photos to give me an audience.
Really, sincerely I thank all
of you, except one person.
That's right, his name is Caleb,
and he's from Kansas City, Missouri.
Look at him.
Caleb thinks he's so much better than me.
Got so much attitude Caleb.
Who are you to judge me Caleb.
I'm out here trying day in day out,
whenever I come out on this
stage, I see you, judging me.
Same look my father gave
me every day of my life.
Here my name is Caleb.
I despise you.
It's you or me Caleb, one of us has to go.
There isn't room in this
theater for both of us.
Technically, there is, plenty of room your
too dimensional, take
up much space but still,
I got my eye on you Caleb.
Caleb and I are going
to lunch after the show.
What are you doing that for?
He's a cool guy. I like him.
Oh, so suddenly you're Caleb's pal.
Well, I'm not his pal,
he says lots of nice stuff
about me and frankly, I like it.
Okay, alright. Fine,
be friends with Caleb.
I will